Nachdem wir alle Elemente von VQE durchgegangen sind,
fassen wir zusammen, was wir gelernt haben, und schauen, wie ein Quantencomputer es ausführt.
Wir beginnen mit unserem geschickt gewählten Referenzzustand, einem parametrisierten circuit,
einer anfänglichen Parameterwahl und einem Hamiltonian.
Diese übergeben wir an unseren Quantencomputer.
Bevor der Hamiltonian auf dem Ansatz-Zustand ausgeführt werden kann,
müssen wir klassisches Preprocessing des circuit durchführen,
damit er von der Quantenhardware gelesen werden kann – ein Prozess namens Transpilation.
Außerdem ist es wichtig, die Architektur der qubits
in der echten Hardware bestmöglich zu nutzen, um die besten Ergebnisse zu erzielen.
Diese Prozesse werden oft automatisch erledigt, sodass wir uns
nicht explizit um qubit-Konnektivität,
gate-Genauigkeiten und so weiter kümmern müssen.
Jetzt geht es darum, den resultierenden Zustand zu messen
und den Erwartungswert zu schätzen, der anschließend
von einem klassischen Optimierer weiter optimiert wird.
Diese Messung erfolgt durch Rotation der Messbasis
und anschließendes Zusammenführen der Messergebnisse, um den Erwartungswert zu erhalten.
Dieses parametrisierte Ergebnis wird dann
an den klassischen Optimierer übergeben, der neue Parameter für den Zustand findet.
Dann wird der Prozess wiederholt.
Das klassische Preprocessing erstellt einen neuen parametrisierten circuit,
und wir wenden denselben Hamiltonian wie zuvor an.
Beachte, dass wir beim gesamten VQE-Prozess die Zustände nur
über die Parameter verändern, die sich immer weiter dem Grundzustand annähern.
Wir wiederholen dies, bis wir mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden sind.
Und das war's.
Mein Name ist Victoria Lipinska, und das war ein Kurs zum Variational Quantum Eigensolver.